welcome to Hannity buckle up tonight we
have several big breaking news stories
including a disturbing new development
from the FISA Court this is gonna make
your blood boil tonight Plus knives are
out Democratic Party heading to Iowa we
will show you how all of the radical
2020 socialists are now starting to turn
on each other as we predicted also
massive anti-regime protesting going on
in the country of Iran drawing worldwide
attention but many so-called liberals
they are of course notably silent
because it doesn't fit the into their
deranged anti-trump narrative first we
start tonight once again in the swamp
where Nancy Pelosi speaker by name only
and are botched impeachment charade is
now a source of official embarrassment
for top Democrats after months of
screaming urgency urgency urgency also
they could go on vacation
Pelosi inexplicably while she sat on the
bogus articles of impeachment for weeks
what happened to the urgency keep in
mind article 1 section 3 our US
Constitution it states quote the Senate
shall have the sole power to try all
impeachments
sole power by the way the house has the
sole power to impeach and when that
house hands over their partisan garbage
the Senate has every right to dismiss
Pelosi doesn't get to tell the Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell how to
do his constitutional job and what his
role is which is why is McConnell
pointed out Pelosi stall tactics have
achieved nothing except the phony belief
that was urgent to do it so quickly
never was take a look on Friday speaker
Pelosi signal she may finally wind down
her one-woman blockade of a fair and
timely impeachment trial in terms of
influencing Senate proceedings this
strange gambit has achieved absolutely
nothing but it has produced one
unintended side effect the speaker's
efforts to pre-commit the Senate to
carry on an investigation with which our
own house lost patience
concede that the house case is rushed
weak and incomplete alright tonight
President Trump is right police blows he
will go down as the worst speaker in the
history of the country and there's a
really good chance she may lose her job
in November and right now even her
fellow Democrats are trashing the
speaker behind closed doors not working
out well for her let's take a look
you heard the speaker say that she
actually did gain a lot by holding up
these articles of impeachment for three
weeks a lot of skepticism on Capitol
Hill yeah definitely I think it's she
was clearly putting a positive spin on
what a lot of Democrats have privately
said was a failed strategy I do think
there are a lot of Democrats who while
not going on the record and saying it a
lot of them had concerned about this all
right from start to finish Pelosi has
totally botched this obvious political
stunt she announced the inquiry before
the transcript of the phone call with
szalinski we ever knew what was in it
she criticized the call in question
before she even read the transfer
transcript she authorized the
impeachment inquiry without a vote she
appointed a corrupt compromise
congenital liar by the name of yes Adam
Schiff to lead this bogus inquiry and
shift then conducted the shift show
investigation in secret where he first
auditioned behind closed doors the
witness's grooming testimony selectively
leaking material why to shape public
opinion his star witness the so-called
whistleblower non whistleblower hearsay
whistleblower never testified after it
was discovered that he had been
apparently talking to may be
coordinating which shifts office from
the beginning now in the end the only
BAC witness well that information that
testimony was exculpatory for the
President as he refuted the Democrats
wild accusations and yet they still
passed two BS articles of impeachment
zero Republican support while a few
Democrats actually voted against the
articles these are the weakest articles
of impeachment in the history of the
United States not worthy frankly of the
Senate's time and despite their best
efforts even the mob and the media
failed to bolster the support they
wanted look at this according to News
Buster's over the past 100 days
a whopping 3/4 of the media's coverage
of President Trump is centered around
impeachment and naturally 93% of that
negative but Americans are not buying it
look at the Real Clear Politics average
the polls have shifted in the
president's favor and now Pelosi is
desperately trying to save face good
luck with that mission in life we have
confidence in our case that is
impeachable and this president is
impeached for life regardless of any
gamesmanship on the part of Mitch
McConnell however that could still come
to bear but we're confident in the
impeachment and we think that it is
enough testimony to remove him from
office how now the only person less
self-aware than Speaker name only Pelosi
might be her corrupt compromised
colleague the congenital liar Adam
Schiff and his shift show now today he
appeared on the hard-hitting news show
the view on ABC
you know the Screamfest where the hosts
all hate each other apparently according
to page six and there is the compromise
can get genital lier where he of all
people complaining the Senate won't
fulfill their constitutional duty oh
really
when he won a real program hey take a
look told me that he believes he is
above the law unaccountable and we
needed to move forward even if the
Senate won't do their constitutional
duty we in the house need to do ours so
why is the congenital liar appearing on
the view every late-night show that will
take him why not this show we offered
him three hours non-stop
the radio show with 625 of the best talk
radio affiliates in the country one hour
thanks to this great audience the number
one show on all the cable news oh that's
right he's afraid I'll actually have to
answer for his malignant behavior after
all this is the coward who afforded 0
right 0 due process zero basic
fundamental fairness the President Trump
the way Newt Gingrich and Republicans
did with Bill Clinton
it appears he tampered perhaps with
witnesses leaked material to shape
public opinion and heard a fraudulent
evidence into the official record member
he actually fabricated a transcript that
didn't exist on the president's call
with the Ukrainian
president and of course he lied about
all of it Schiff doesn't apparently care
about constitutional duties
now since 2016 Democrats have cared
about one thing one thing only
destroying any means possible Donald
Trump this impeachment charade was their
desperate last-ditch attempt and it has
been an abject failure meanwhile the
Trump agenda continues to be a massive
success according to new data from the
Bureau of Labor Statistics the
unemployment rate Wow in spite of all of
the noise and all of the impeachment and
all the conspiracy theories and all the
hoaxes it is now at the lowest rate
since 1969 many of you watching probably
more important yet that's three point
five percent the labor of underutilized
rates they also are at all-time lows
look at this wage growth for low and
middle income earners you know the
Forgotten men and women
disproportionately negatively impacted
by Biden and Obama's economy yep they're
actually outpacing the growth of
high-income earners
Wow the rich and earnings growth among
every race every gender tax bracket is
far exceeding the obama-biden years the
economy now by every measure firing on
all cylinders the election is only 295
days away